Wow, I can’t believe it! This new
AI can look at a real tennis player,
and put them in a computer game where we can
play with them. This looks absolutely amazing,
and doing this the hard way has
so far been absolutely impossible.
But what about the easy way? Exciting as this may
seem, perhaps there is nothing new here. You see,
we can already do something like this
through motion capture. What is that?
Well, you put a human in a studio,
attach these little balls to them,
and record their motion. Then, transfer
this motion to a virtual character. Easy.
However, this paper has an incredible twist.
And that twist is that this can do the same
but without the balls. No cameras, gyroscopes,
or any additional machinery is required. Just
the raw video feed, and the learning happens
from that. That sounds incredible - but how?
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Well, there are previous works
that try to do something similar,
but the precision of these motions was almost
never satisfactory. Especially for tennis,
where almost hitting a ball is not
nearly good enough. I am very proud to
say that all three of these papers have been
showcased here on Two Minute Papers before.
But this new technique, this one
can do it even better. First,
we give it the raw video feed of the players, and
then, it will try to estimate their motion. So,
are we done? Well, unfortunately not. Not even
close. Look! This motion is still way too jerky
and imprecise to be used in practice.
It is full of artifacts. So, what now?
Well, now comes the magic! Here, a
computer simulation is built that
tries to reproduce this motion, but
this one cannot be jerky because it
is within a video game where the laws
of physics are intact. In reality,
people don’t move like that. And with this
simulation, hmm… this is looking so much better!
From now on, we can take a target
position that we start from,
and simulate many-many possible motions types.
Then, we can grab a controller and perform
these serves, top spin, back spin hits, slices,
you name it. And they look absolutely
incredible. Yes, I hear you asking,
Károly, are you sure that this is a
simulation? Well, if you look here,
here is the proof. Yes, simulations today
are getting so advanced that we need to see
these 3D models to be absolutely sure that
this is indeed a computer simulation. Wow.
And it gets better. Here is the interesting
part: this is not just a copying machine,
although just copying the motion from
these videos would also be quite a feat,
given the occlusions and tiny, but super
important wrist motions that are really
hard to see from the footage. But with this
system, we can even highlight a region where
we would like to hit the ball, and the
motions will be synthesized accordingly.
We can run the same simulation with a
number of different target locations,
and all of the synthesized motions will be
believable, and accurate. Loving it. Or we
can also ask the player to hit the ball to the
same point from different starting positions.
And it will work not only for the easier cases,
but in more difficult scenarios too where
you can barely catch that ball. So good!
And now, hold on to your papers Fellow
Scholars, because it can not only do all this,
but it can even learn the individual
style of famous tennis players.
Right and left-handed players work too,
and it can even simulate a one or two
handed backhand shot, depending on
the style of the player at hand.
And if that is possible at all, it gets even
better! If we can simulate one virtual human,
why not make a game by simulating two
playing against each other? I have to say,
if I look closely, I can still see that this
is a simulation, but if you squint a little,
it’s easy to think that this is
real footage. That is an incredible
achievement both in the graphics, and
in the animation departments. Bravo!
Styles are particularly interesting here,
because if it would have only one style,
two players playing that same style
would not look nearly as interesting
at this footage with one left
and one right-handed player.
What I particularly like is that
there is barely any foot sliding,
a problem that you see in almost every single
paper in this area. They usually compete on
how little foot sliding there is, no foot
sliding at all is almost unheard of. Wow. Also,
almost none of the jitters from the original
motions are there in this footage. The foot
sliding here is less than an inch, and the
jitter is almost nonexistent. All gone.
And if we remove just one small
part of this new proposed system,
things can go really bad. For instance,
if the wrist motions are captured with
just a bit of inaccuracy, the hits will go
completely wrong. You have to get everything
nearly perfectly for this to work. And
the scientists absolutely nailed it.
So, how many hundreds of hours did the AI
have to sift through to learn all this? Well,
it was not in the order of hundreds of hours,
but get this, only 4.5 hours of video footage.
Goodness. I don’t even know what to say.
When using the full system, the hit rates can
reach up to a hundred percent, which sounds
almost impossible to me. They absolutely knocked
this out of the court with this paper, and thus,
it was published at SIGGRAPH, perhaps the most
prestigious conference in computer graphics. In my
view, it is like winning the olympic gold medal
of computer graphics research. I have to say,
it is very well deserved. Bravo! This
might be the future of video games.